voici tel qu'on leur enseigne sur les
bords du gange l'ase hanau posture du
lion spécialement destiné à calmer
l'individu et à refouler la coller voici
comment les journalistes des années 50
commentait cette fatigue fraîchement
arrivé en france le yoga à l'époque
cette discipline nouvelle paraissait
pare-feu lui donnait cher monsieur vous
qui accumule les soucis et tracas
souvenez-vous du lion seuls quelques
adeptes étaient prêts à partir vivre
l'expérience en inde auprès de leur
gourou dans ce qu'on appelle des ashrams
l'ashram c'est une sorte de couvents et
c'est du monde entier que ses disciples
viennent suivre le cours de vedanta le
célèbre guillamat young début des années
60 le maître spirituel shri mahesh était
le premier professeur de hatha yoga à
s'installer en france il a ouvert de
nombreuses écoles de yoga et il insité
sur l'universalité de la pratique
tout le monde peut adapter là ce n'est
pas uniquement réservée pour les hindous
mais occident comme l'on peut adapter
yoga quelques années plus tard le yoga
va se démocratiser en occident d'abord
avec le mouvement hippie mais aussi avec
quelques stars mondiales les beatles par
exemple
[Musique]
il était une fois quatre garçons je
n'aime pas le george et ringo les
beatles ont à nous qui n'a de leur
présence et de leur gloire aspirer à
retrouver la pureté et la simplicité
ils ont rencontré le mari chi ils ont
été conquis et ils l'ont rejoint avec
leurs épouses dans sa retraite de
rishikesh au cash ligne en france les
démonstrations de yoga sont apparus sur
les plateaux télé dès 1963 et en 1970
françoise hardy s'est même laissé filmer
en pleine méditation
bref la discipline continue de
progresser je crois que c'est une remise
en question de soi mains d'une
permanence et que comme motivation
principale
il y as au départ à une certaine forme
d'humilité
et si le yoga en amuser plus d'un à
l'époque les chiffres ne trompent pas
2,8 millions d'adeptes en france et 300
millions à travers le monde aujourd'hui
le gars de nos jours fait partie du top
5 des sports les plus pratiqués par les
français
[Musique]